(clicking and chiming sounds)
- We hope you enjoy the next
two days and we're very please
to kick off the conference
with a really wonderful panel
which Lucy is gonna introduced.
- Thank you.
Not really a panel but
- It's two speakers.
- You call that a panel?
- It's a panel.
- Oh alright, okay (laughs).
We are please to have Shelton Dent
who's standing for Nancy Bargmann.
Well Shelton has spoken
at this conference before
and he doesn't need to be
described as a stand-in.
He's a stand alone speaker
and he is the assistant deputy
director of programs and policy branch
for the department of
developmental services.
Has worked with people
with disabilities for nearly 40 years
and has been with DDS
for, I believe 31 years.
And he will be followed by on the panel.
- On the panel.
- Eric Zigman who is
the executive director
of Golden Gate Regional Center
and I didn't get all that
background info on you Eric.
So you have to describe
yourself a bit more
- [Eric] I'm not that interesting.
- Not that interesting.
- Oh I bet it is, I bet it is.
- And so Mr. Dent, will you
come to the podium please.
Welcome back.
- Thank you, thank you.
Good morning everybody.
- [Audience] Good morning.
- Alright, first of all Nancy
Bargmann wanted to make sure
that I apologize profusely for her.
She sincerely wanted to
come to this meeting.
She knows that there's a lot of clinicians
and such that she doesn't
get to speak to very often
so she really wanted to be apart of this.
But one of the things that got in the way
but is helpful to all of
us is the budget hearings.
So she had to go up to the Senate
and our representatives to talk
about our next state budget.
And she's doing that and
doing a great job of it.
Some of you might have
saw her on the CalChannel
just yesterday, talking
about budget issues
and that is what called her away.
One of the things she asked me to do
and it still says Nancy
Bargmann on her presentation
'cause it is her presentation.
I'll try to do it justice
but it is what she wanted
me to go over for you today.
An update on the developmental
disabilities service system.
So I'm also suppose to let you know
that I don't have any thing to disclose.
So with that said, The Lanterman
Developmental Disabilities
Services Act, as you
know was passed in 1969.
And it just celebrated
its 50th anniversary.
But the biggest thing about
this Lanterman Entitlement Act
is that it's the only Entitlement Act
of all of the 50 states.
So California has the only
entitlement for services
for people with
developmental disabilities.
We have a mission statement,
we have a vision statement.
The mission statement
is to ensure that people
with developmental
disabilities have the ability
to live lives just as you and I do.
Our mission statement
is that and our vision
building partnerships
and supporting choices
is really about a system
of partnering with folks
so that our system works together as one.
It's a system structure
for people to work together
and agencies to work together
and everybody to work together
to make services support
available for people
with developmental disabilities.
When we look at our system structure,
you'll notice that it starts
with the governor's office of course.
We have the health and
human services agency
which the departmental
and developmental services
is apart of and then we have
the state developmental centers
as well as one state
operated community facility.
Which is run by the state
and has state employees
and then we contract
with 21 regional centers.
Often times people call the department
and ask us to, have an issue
with the regional center
and they want department
of developmental services
to address it immediately.
And we often times, unless
it has something to do with
a violation of law regulation.
We have to refer them back
to the regional center
because the regional centers are all
and a lot of people are surprised by this.
The regional centers are all
private non-profit organizations
and they answer to a board of directors.
Other than violations
of law and regulation
everything else, we can address things
that have to do with a
violation of law and regulation
but everything else has to go through
their regional center
director and their board.
So one of the big examples
that we get is often times people,
vendors might get vendored to serve
like a residential provider
might get vendored to serve six
or get license to serve six people.
And the regional center tells
them, well vendor you forfour
and they'll call the department and say,
I got license for six people.
I want six people in my home.
The regional centers says
they'll only give me four.
That is not something that the department
can do something about.
That is a regional center
and their board of directors
decision to serve people in that manner.
And that's how regional
centers were set up
to do what their local
community feels is the most
appropriate way to serve folks.
So that's not a violation
of law and regulation
and when we get calls
about that we refer them
back to the regional center
because that's the way our system works.
The regional centers have case managers
that help coordinate services
and they vendor service providers
who actually provide direct services
and supports to our consumers.
And all of that is done through a IPP
and a person centered planning process.
So as I said they contract
with these 21 regional centers,
the 21 regional centers
are private non profit.
They are 21 regional centers
to cover all 56 counties of California.
Regional centers work with
approximately 45,000 vendors
who provide those direct services
and we work with a system of
partners, other organizations,
stakeholder groups, individuals, families
to implement the vision
of The Lanterman Act.
So what's been going
on the last few years?
More than a few years I guess.
From 2002-2016, you can see the growth
in our consumer population.
As of December of 2016,
we're serving 304,000 people.
When you look at the
regional center population,
from the smallest regional center,
Redwood Coast Regional Center,
up at the northern tip of California
verses Inland Regional
Center in the San Bernadine.
You see Redwood Coast serving 3600 folks
and Inland Regional Center 31,300 folks
with the average regional
center serving 14,000 folks.
The way this consumer population
is growing essentially
we could start a new
regional center every year.
Consumer population by age.
As we gather this type of
information at the department,
this is one of the areas
where we look at trends
to see what's going on and
see what kind of resources
need to be developed and
what kind of legislation
might need to be addressed to
address some of the trends.
One of the things you'll notice here
is that our elderly seniors
are beginning to grow
which tells us that our folks
are starting to live a lot longer.
One of the things that we've
done to address this is
we've worked with Community Care Licensing
and you may have notice this already
but a lot of the Community
Care Licensing folks
are now starting to allow
people to age in place.
So folks that are in adult
residential facilities
can stay in adult residential facilities.
They don't have to simply
move because they turn 60.
Usually the adult residential facilities
limit is up to 59 years of age.
But Community Care
Licensing is working with us
and now for the most
part is allowing people
unless there's some drastic differences
between the consumer population.
Will allow people to stay in
adult residential facilities
for as long as they choose.
Consumer population by living arrangement.
As you can see developmental
center population continuing
to go down, less people are living those.
Of course that's because of our initiative
to close all of our developmental centers.
And as always have been the
case, regional centers work hard
to support people and their families.
So the family home, parent/guardian
still continues to grow
and people continue to
live in their family home
as long as possible.
When we look at the consumer
population by diagnosis.
Another thing that you see,
you can clearly see that autism
growth continues to climb rapidly.
This is not a secret and
we continue to provide work
on developing resources
to address those issues.
Population of developmental centers
and state operated community facilities.
You can see the steep
decline that started in 1994.
I don't know if people
remembered the Coffel years
when we were court ordered
to move over 2000 people
out of developmental centers
within a five year period
that accounts for the steep decline
right there in the early years.
But ever since that time, there
have been laws put in place
and the lack of federal funding
for some of our developmental centers,
actually for all of our
developmental centers at this point.
Which has cause us to make the initiative
to close all of our development centers.
And now we have less than
a thousand people living
in developmental centers.
And then we look at a few budget things
and of course that is also driven
by the fact that we are closing
our developmental centers.
So there's more growth
in community services
from 16/17 it was $5.8
billion to community services
and proposed for 17/18 is $6.4 billion.
That's an interesting stats
by itself because as she said,
I've been doing this services
for developmental disabilities
for almost 40 years
and I remember when the budget
for the whole regional center system
was less than $20 million.
So we're in the billions
now and we're working hard.
And the reason that we're
able to be in the billions
and the reason that we still
have an Entitlement Act
is the fact that we are able
to capture more federal dollars.
It is imperative that the department
and our service system
captures every federal dollars
we can get in order to
maintain the entitlement
provided by The Lanterman Act.
As you can see, a little less than 50%
of our funds are federal but as we move
from the developmental centers systems
moving everybody into the community.
We'll have a lot more pressure still
to maintain those federal dollars
and the federal government
will still be looking at the community.
In terms of the dollars that
are spent for federal funding.
So we'll be under the same
types of pressures really
as the developmental centers were.
Developmental centers were
unable to maintain certification
which is partly what's
led to their closure,
other than the fact that
people shouldn't have to live
in state institutions.
But the other, the
driver of that has to do
with they could not
maintain their certification
which meant total general fund dollars
were going into funding
the developmental centers.
That same pressure will
be community because
through our home and community
based services waivers
that captures a great
deal of federal funding.
They'll be out monitoring
to make sure we're meeting
or complying with the home and
federal waiver requirements.
And if by chance we're not
following those requirements,
they will cut federal funding
which is why there is a lot
pressure on regional centers
and our service system to
capture those federal dollars
and be in compliance with federal waivers.
So who do we serve?
As you can see, the Hispanic community
and our white community
are the primary drivers.
And when we look at who we
serve, we also have to be mindful
of the unrepresented communities.
One of the big things
that's talked about a lot
at the legislature and
within the department
and within the regional
centers now has to do
with disparity in services
to different ethnic groups.
A very interesting issue
that's come up with this
and another slide will
show you has to do with,
even though White is still the largest.
They're starting to go down and Hispanic
is starting to be a large area of growth.
However when you look at
the utilization of services,
you'll see that Hispanic is not utilizing
a lot of services that
are available to them.
We find this can be of
course the issue with culture
but it is something
that we want to address.
And it's something that the
legislature wants to address
as there have also been
a lot complaints about,
in different regions where the population
in Hispanic or Black is high
and yet utilization of
services seems to be unequal.
So as you can see from this slide,
even though Hispanic is high.
They only utilize 79% of the
services that are authorized.
Another interest thing that we found
with the White population.
They use 84% but they
also are the largest user
of residential services
which is interesting.
So what are some of the recent changes
that have come about
at the department now?
I'm sure many of you remember back in 2009
when there were system wide reductions.
How difficult it was to
get services for anybody.
Now that the budget has
started to make a return
and we've got a little
more funding to our system.
We're able to as you can see
restore early start program.
Restoration of prior services
provider payment reductions,
rate increases for specific service types
and to provide additional compensation
for direct service providers.
There's additional funding
for a paid internship program
and service provider placement
incentive funding for competitive
integrated employment.
And I find this one to
be really interesting
'cause when we did stakeholders meetings
to talk about how to implement
this paid internship program.
Legislature provided $10
million for this program
and as I said earlier
that there was a point
when we only got $20 million
for the entire system
and we were able to get $10
million for this one program.
We've come a long ways.
And we have additional
funding to regional centers
to address purchase
and service disparities
for underserved populations.
In fact we get $11 million
annually to address
that issue I just talked about
between the different ethnicities.
We also received increased funding
to address state wide
minimum wage increases.
Increase funding to facilitate development
of community resources for
individuals transitioning
from DCs and to meet
challenging service needs.
We have increased funding for
regional center operations
including reducing case load ratios
and new positions at regional centers.
Some of those new positions
include a cultural specialist,
an employment specialist
and a federal program specialist too.
To again ensure that regional
centers are able to comply
with home and community
based service waiver issues.
As I said those dollars are going to be
critical to our system.
And then new DDS
priorities and initiatives.
Of course one of the reasons
Nancy is not here has to do
with new legislation and funding
so it's gonna be incumbent
upon us to operationalize
and implement any new
legislation and funding.
Home and community based settings.
The federal rules are out
there for people to review.
They're critical for our federal dollars
and we need to be in compliance
with the federal home
and community based settings rules.
By March of 2019, we have
new community service models.
Enhance behavior support homes.
We have adult residential facilities
for persons with special
health care needs.
We have added delayed egress
secure perimeter services
to our residential
programs that's available
for folks to use when needed.
One of the things I would
say about the enhance
or what is also called the (ARFPSHN)
or the Adult Residential
Facility for Persons
with Special Healthcare Needs.
They are starting to grow rapidly.
They have proven to be a
very effective and successful
service for people that
are medically fragile.
In fact, hopefully one of the initiatives
might be to spread that
program for children
that are medically fragile.
That's what we're looking at next.
We already have, in past
I've talked about (ARFPSHN)
program because it was modeled
after the special program
for children which was
previously called Bates Homes.
And the (ARFPSHN) was modeled after that
but the problem with the Bates Homes
is that they can only be done
in small family homes or foster homes.
We wanna expand that program
so it can be done in a group home.
So that it doesn't have to just be run
by the person that owns the home.
Then of course we have the
self-determine patient program
and I don't know if people know.
We've been trying to get this
self-determination program
off the ground for quite some time.
Actually we're the only
state that had to apply
to the federal government for
the self-determination program
and we send our application
in way back in 2014, December of 2014.
And we're still responding to questions
from the federal government to try to get
this thing off the ground.
Even once we get it off the
ground it's still just suppose
to be a three year pilot
and could serve 2500 people.
But we feeling like we're
getting a lot closer
to answering all their
questions and hopefully,
we'll get this thing going
in a short period of time.
One of the things about the
self-determination program
that people may not notice that people
get to direct their own budget.
So depending on what their IPP needs are,
they'll receive a budget to
carry out that on their own
and they can choose
their service providers.
Who they wanna get services from,
who they want to get their support from.
It should be a very interesting
program once it gets here.
And then again, I wanna reduce inequities
and disparities in our system.
Reporting on regional centers,
I don't know if people
have looked at our website lately
but we have a dashboard on our website now
where a lot of regional center data
on individual regional
centers can be found.
And so you can look at our website,
you can look at the dashboard
for regional centers
and get a lot of data on
what that particular
regional center is doing.
And of course the
developmental center closure
and transition activities.
There's a great deal of
work and activity going on
to transition people appropriately
from the developmental centers.
One of the big complaints
during the Coffel years
was that we moved people too fast.
I can tell you that that's not the case
with the developmental centers closures
for Fairview, Porterville and Sonoma
which are the three remaining
developmental centers.
There is a lot of transition
activity that goes on
with each individual that moves
from those developmental centers.
And regional centers are
doing a great deal of work
to develop appropriate resources for folks
and see that they are moved appropriately.
And once they move the quality of services
they provide is appropriate as well.
And then we continue to
provide community development
funds to regional centers
to develop resources.
Not only for people coming
out of developmental centers
but for people that are
in our college hospital,
jails and we still have some consumers
that live out of state
that we wanna bring back
to California.
'Cause we believe California
is the most appropriate
and our system was developed
to serve people in California.
So those folks that had
to be placed out of state
for one reason or
another, regional centers
are developing resources
so that they can bring
them back to California.
And with that, are there any questions?
Okay.
- We can barrage you both
with questions afterwards
so thank you.
(audience applauding)
And so now it's my pleasure to introduce
for the local perspective as it were.
Mr. Eric Zigman who is
the executive director of
Golden Gate Regional Center
and give us some background
on yourself please Eric.
Welcome.
- Thank you.
- I'm gonna get a glass of water.
Thank you Dr. Green.
I didn't wanna do that one.
Shelton was speaking because
I knew I would spill it
and fall down and stuff so thanks so much
for inviting us to speak today.
I feel really honored.
This conference has a great reputation
and I know you guys will
have a great couple of days
with all the sessions that are going on.
So I will give you a brief,
short biography of me.
I started in direct service in
1989 in a sheltered workshop
with 110 people with intellectual
and developmental disabilities,
and we had about 20 folks
working in the community.
And over 15 years, we shut
the sheltered workshop
and got 110 people
working in the community.
This was in Santa Cruz, California.
It was outside of the closure
of Agnews Developmental Center
and the part I was lucky to play there.
The closure of the workshop
and moving people in the community.
Employment was certainly
one of the high water marks
of the work I've been involved in.
So after that I played a lot
of roles in an organization
like many of the old timers in the system
including Nancy Bargmann.
I had a lot of different
roles that hopefully prepared
me for the work we're doing now.
I was involved in services
and supported employment
and as I said and in supporting living
and independent living
and in children's rest bed
and just a broad variety
of the provision of services
and learned a lot from the
people we served in those years.
And then I consulted for nine
years which was a shock to me.
I thought I'd do it for a year
but the work was just so interesting.
A lot of it had to do
with the closure of Agnews
Developmental Center in the
middle of those nine years.
Certainly between 2004 and
2009 when Agnews closed
and that included work to
help East Bay group found
Algeria Community Living.
Which is a wonderful
provider in the East Bay,
all throughout the East Bay.
Also I was director of the
quality management system
for the Bay Area project which
was the closure of Agnews.
Where got to see the
transformation of folks
from living in an institution
to living in the community
and I got to see 300 individual stories
really of the stunning
changes in people's lives.
People in their 60s
and 70s and 80s and 90s
mostly moved out into the community
and really got a new lease on life
and got to do things extraordinary,
sort of transformational things so.
And then the last three years prior to me
coming to Golden Gate nine months ago.
I was the CEO of The Pomeroy Center
used to be called the Rec Center
for the handicapped or (RCH).
A legacy 60 year old provider
in the Southwest corner
of San Francisco that was
a leader in its history.
Some decades around recreation and people
with developmental disabilities
and that was a great experience.
So now I'm charged with
running one of these
interestingly these
called regional centers.
There's only 21 in the state.
Shelton referenced that
we are 5O1c3 non profits
and some of the greatest innovation
from the highest highs and lowest lows
have come from the fact that
we are a non profit organization.
Though we do much of
the work of government.
We are not government
agencies, not yet anyway.
So one thing that's very interesting is
and I really never completely fact checked
where this came from.
But I believe that the
original design in the regional
centers was to add a regional
center for every million
in the general population in California.
In which case today,
we'd 40 regional centers
rather than the 21 and
then as Shelton mentioned.
The other way to look at
that is just the intakes
into the system.
Each year about 13000,
14000 and that's the size of
a medium sized regional center.
So we are taking in about the equivalent
of the people we serve in terms of
adding a regional center each year.
So I am going figure out
how to use these, forward.
Alright, so those are my disclosures.
No products, no services.
I'm not selling anything but
goodwill and civil rights.
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
Alright so here's what I'll try to do
in the next 20 minutes or so
and leave some time for
questions for Shelton and I.
We're gonna talk a little bit
about the history of the regional centers
and the Lanterman Act in particular.
Some of this duplicates a little bit of
what Shelton had said but hopefully gives
you a little bit different perspective.
I mean I think the 16th
annual conference really
some of the key language around the point
is to really look at
community living broadly.
And transforming systems of care
and the history of The
Lanterman Act really is about
sort of transformation of
different kind of approach
than the typical government
approach to services.
And like any system,
it falls on hard times at different points
and needs renewal and it
feels, hopefully to me
that we're at the beginning
of a renewal period
with the influx of funding that came
into the system this year.
And some of the discussions
that are going on
and certainly the closure
of the institutions.
So let us plow on, I always
like to quote physicists
when we're doing a
conference on healthcare.
No, I'm always been taken by the phrase,
we stand on the shoulder of giants,
and that was Isaac Newton's
phrase about Galeao, I believe.
Really all the work we do is predicated
on the work that comes before us.
And especially when we
talk about civil rights.
You gotta be in it for the long haul
so it's really good to
know where you came from
and then it's also helpful
to know where you're going.
But we do really have a 50 year history
and I wanted to put a
context to what was happening
when leading up to The
Lanterman Act being passed.
And this slide could
really be fact checked.
(audience laughing)
I would like, in my revised version
which is also better
that's it's not up here.
Don't think you're a civil rights experts
when you're not and so I
did some of this from memory
and when I really looked on the internet.
I was like, well I got it pretty close.
I thinking I really wanted
like an organizational
like New York Times or
CNN to really fact check
so to make sure that it's not fake news.
I'm not trying to have any fake news.
But really all these things were going on.
The Civil Rights Act of 1964.
Selma didn't have a bus strike.
Montgomery, Alabama had the bus strike
but Selma did have a March.
So I got that half right
and then the 1964 Democratic Convention
did have a silent vigil for civil rights
which was fascinating
which I guess my mistake
led me to more information.
But I was really referring to
the 1968 Democratic convention
where it was much less than silent
and there were a lot advocates
including some people
with disabilities
protesting the Vietnam war
and other social changes.
The March on Washington
and the Stonewall Riots
for at that time gay rights now
would be called LBGT rights.
The Second Wave of Feminism,
I mean all these things played
into The Lanterman Act and the
Independent Living Movement.
I mean the Ed Roberts
Center is across the Bay
and Berkeley and I urge
everyone if they have a chance
to visit it over the Ashby BART station.
Ed Roberts was a giant and
in moving things forward
for all people with
disabilities and so certainly
played a role in that due to human.
Others in that movement
and so that's all that
was swirling around during
that time in mid 60s
when the first pilot project was announced
to tri-regional centers as an alternative
to institutional living.
And I will say some of Shelton's
data is very powerful to me
especially the chart on the reduction
of people in institutions.
In 1965, there were 13500
individuals with intellectual
and development disabilities
in state institutions
and there was waiting list.
That was like we are full up,
there was no room at the end
and by the end of this next fiscal year,
we should be under 500.
And so that's the object
lesson in civil rights change.
It takes way more longer
than you would want
but that is a powerful change
in our world, in our system.
So in the March on Washington.
The famous, I have a dream speech was done
by Martin Luther King.
And one of the fascinating
little side stories
is Mahalia Jackson is a gospel singer,
at the time would often sing
before Dr. King's speeches.
And he had asked her to
sing a particular song
before the I have a dream speech
and the I have a dream
speech really didn't have
I have a dream in it.
That was really, he took
that and extemporaneously
inserted it from one
of his other speeches.
He hadn't really intended
to have that part
and if you watch the YouTube video.
My whole theme today is
fact checking me, I think.
(audience laughing)
If you look at the YouTube
video of Dr. King's speech
or at least if it has
enough quality of sound.
You can hear Mahalia
Jackson in the background
saying, "Tell them about the dream Martin,
"tell them about the dream."
And so he pivots into that section
and it's very powerful for me lately
about what role we all play in leadership.
Here's this performer who
kind of played a seminal role
in changing Dr. King's speech
or making it this
incredibly famous speech.
So I do love that story
and you can check it out.
It is online.
So Dr. King said that he had dream
that his four little
children would one day live
in a world where they were not judged
by the color of their skin
but by the content of their character
and I think The Lanterman
Act really for people
with intellectual and
developmental disabilities
in California certainly was the
launch of that kind of idea.
That people would be
looked at as people first.
So I wanted to take a moment
before I delve in The Lanterman Act
to just talk about identity and disability
and the importance of language.
I'm not really, language
probably not a good to say.
I'm not really a stickler on language.
I would like behavior and
actions to really speak louder
than language but in this case.
It really made an impression
on me as I learn people
first language and the difference
between saying a disabled
person or a autistic person
and a person with autism or
person with a disability.
The importance here is
it sets the individual
and the individual's identity,
this core of explaining themselves.
And so it's a change from
saying that the adjective,
the modifier is the important
thing about the person.
That they're defined by their deficits
and it moves it to
saying I'm a human being
that whatever challenges I have in life.
And whatever special gifts and talents
that informs my identity
but that's not the sum
total of my identity.
People don't say I'm a
glasses wearing person.
It's like a person who wears glasses
so that's really important to me.
It connects to the Dr.
King quote that it's about
the individual's identity
and we all know this.
The more you work with an individual,
the less you see them
as your first impression
and the more you see them as sort of
the core identity of who they are.
That's informed by their life's experience
and sometimes by their disabilities.
So I wanna go a little bit deeper
into The Lanterman Act Promise.
It's really the promise of equal access
against the promise of support.
People hear the word entitlement
and they think of preference
and preferential treatment
and it's important to bring them back
really to a civil rights frame for me.
And say it's about equal access.
It's about leveling the playing field.
It's about letting people
live, work and play
and have an access to that as people
without disabilities have access to it.
It's not about any special "treatment".
I'm gonna move, I think
quickly through these slides
somewhat but the first
page of The Lanterman Act
is like a declaration of
independence for the country.
It's really well written.
Art Bolton was a staffer
for Frank Lanterman
and others but Art
really played a huge role
in drafting this language.
And it says right at the beginning that
"The State of California
accepts a responsibility
"for persons with
developmental disabilities
"and an obligation to them
that it must discharge."
It affects hundreds of
thousands of children and adults
directly and I love this part,
and having an important
impact on the lives
of their families, neighbors
and entire communities.
Developmental disabilities
presents social, medical,
economic, legal I would say issues now.
They said problems in 1969
of extreme importance.
So what it really do?
All of this is contained
again in that first page
of The Lanterman Act.
The first 4501 of welfare
and institutions code.
It created an entitlement.
The entitlement really got rolling in 1985
when the Arc of California sued the DDS.
Brought a case that went
to the state supreme court.
In 1985, state supreme court
decision basically says yes.
That obligation means
you have an obligation
both to fund the system and if
the system runs out of money.
Then the Department of
Developmental Services,
Shelton's gonna go back to the legislature
and ask for more money.
When it runs out of money
that was the original intent
in the supreme court decision
and that the Department
of Development Services
would have some limited
influence on regional centers.
At the service level, the IPP,
the individual program
plan Shelton reference
would be the driver of services
and the regional centers
would be responsible to their communities
to provide services in a way
that best met those needs of the IPP.
And the Department of
Developmental Services
will play a funding role and a legal role
but direct regional centers in what to do.
And that really is where the flexibility
in the system has come from
and the ability to innovate in a way
that we could never done over 50 years
if we were state owned and
operated, no offense Shelton.
(audience laughing)
It also established the IPP
which is one of my mentors
who's passed away last year,
Barbara Maizie of Contra Costa ARC.
Just hammered about the IPP
being the legal source document.
It all comes from the IPP but it's true.
That's how we plan one person at a time
and don't have cookie cutter
one size fits all services.
We have services that are
responsive to the individual.
The other things Lanterman
Act right away does is
have this great language
around establishing
an array of services
based on needs and choices
and that will be regardless of age.
And regardless of degree of disability
which is a very important
thing and sometimes
gets in the way when
we're trying to explain
to legislatures especially
new legislatures
and give them an idea
of the people we serve.
It's really helpful to
bring a vast variety
of the people we serve because it's hard
if you haven't had an
experience of intellectual
and developmental
disabilities in your family
or neighborhood or friends.
To really be able to talk
about just the vast diversity
in difference and presenting
needs and different ways
of communicating is represented
by the people we serve.
And then this great phase of integration
into the main stream
life of the community.
Who knew the community
even had a mainstream life.
But it does and we're
still chasing that goal
and then another phrase
that's an awesome phrase
is that and again, relates
to the equal access
not preferential treatment.
The whole system is to help
people with intellectual
and developmental disabilities approximate
the patterns of everyday living available
to people without disabilities,
and now we're seeing that language
echoed in the ACBS final rule.
The new federal expectations
or current federal expectations
that we have to comply with,
that all the country has to
comply with by March of 2019.
But right there in The Lanterman Act
and this great phrase
we really wanna pursue.
We're not pursuing them,
they're coming to us.
We really wanna help people pursue
their own personal futures.
And for me I always like to think of
that as we're here to help people
have equal access by meeting their needs
but also by helping them define
and meet their aspirations.
It's not just all about sort of
Maslow's lowest levels of meeting needs.
It's also higher level of aspirations
so we are charged with
supporting people in.
Okay so that's The Lanterman
Act script notes version.
So like the Civil Rights Act of 1964
and the national supreme court decision
of Brown verses The Board of Education.
In our country and in our culture,
we often pass laws and then
we have to have court cases
that come along behind
and enforce the law.
And when I went to graduate school
at another university
here in San Francisco.
I got to be with people
who provided services
or management leadership
from disability services
from all over the country
and a couple from Finland.
We had two women, Helen and
Tina who were doing disability
services in Finland and
when we went through
this section on the Civil Rights Act,
Brown verses The Board of Education.
One of them raised their
hands, I don't remember
it was probably Tina
not Helen and she said,
"Wait, why did you need
to have a court case
"to enforce the law?
"Why didn't people in your country
"just follow the law
when you pass the law?
(audience laughing)
We all looked at each other
from the United States
and went, you must not be from here.
(audience laughing)
This very northern European
thing that you pass a law so
follow the law so that happened
with The Lanterman Act.
I mean it was in place
and it was chugging along
but it was really that 1985
states supreme court decision
that said no, no it's true.
You got to put your money
where your mouth is California.
You got to find a system
and has to be based
on individual needs,
not categories of cookie cutter services.
So now we get into the healthcare
within a social justice frame.
And I learn this mostly from my friends
and colleagues and that USF program.
In the disability rights movement
sort of writ large the people
with physical disabilities in particular
were very uncomfortable
with the medical model.
And I remember when we're closing Agnews,
we had a great RN, who may be here today.
Who didn't come from the field
and said why you keep saying medical model
like it's a negative thing.
We in medicine think medical
model kind of make sense
but for people with disabilities,
the medical model really translated
into a disempowering model in our history.
Where the physician would
diagnose that the person
was basically broken and needed to be fix
in various different ways
and would prescribe things
to help them get better and fix them.
But what's even more kind of damaging
was that we as human service professionals
took on this quasi medical model.
Where we were diagnosing
that if Eric just would bathe
more, Eric would be better
regardless of what Eric wanted to do.
And so we kind of diagnosed
folks in the early days
about what they needed to get a job
in the community, for instance.
Not only was disempowering
and rob people of their agency
but it also wasn't effective.
We had folks who would
have to be in workshops
for years and years and years
to be able to get a chance
to have a job in the community.
When if we found somebody
who really was interested
in working in a hospital instead
of having a grooming goal
and hammering on them.
And what normal grooming
was we would take them
to the hospital and say
if you wanna work here,
you're gonna have to take a shower man.
So that was huge change and I
think we're still undergoing
that change in our history.
Some disability rights
advocates that I was with
about a year ago, two
years ago with autism.
We're talking about internalized ableism
which is a fascinating
sort of idea that they had
overcome in their own lives.
This idea that they
weren't working hard enough
to be able to pass for
somebody without a disability
and they internalized that
and it had robbed them
of some of their power.
So one of the things I have at the end
in one of the web links is the
Disability Rights Education
Defense Fund (DREDF).
They have this healthcare stories website
and if you think this is only in the past.
This damage of that approach,
prescriptive approach to people.
They're all kinds of
folks with disabilities
who are on that website
talking about their experience
with the healthcare professionals
and it's fascinating.
Our clients are consumer rights advocate,
now wait we're dropping that language.
Elizabeth Frisbie who is
a great advocate for us
at Golden Gate.
I think we're just saying advocate,
that's what I'm proposing
to have her title be.
She's on one of those stories
and they're all compelling
so I urge you to look at that.
So that was our past.
Where is our trajectory, where
are we headed in the future?
It's really and we're kind
of in the middle of this.
From the medical model to a
person centered thinking model
or nothing about us without us model.
Golden Gates been a leader with along
with Redwood Coast Regional Center
and Tri-counties regional centers
we've attempted to be a leader
in person centered thinking.
It's a whole sort of
way to approach planning
that really puts the individual served
in the place that The Lanterman
Act says they should be.
And one of the more powerful,
simple tools is just
to help folks who are
facilitating those meetings.
Understand the difference
between what's important for someone
which is sort of relates
to all the prescriptive things
we know as professionals
that will help somebody in their lives.
But then to differentiate what's important
for someone from what's important to them
so that there's a space cleared for them
to be able to clarify that
to the group in some way.
So the people around them
if they're not able to articulate
what's important to them.
Help really clarify what
and again what they're aspirations are.
Where are they're aspiring to be.
Where they thrive.
So what is healthcare within
a social justice frame
means for me the individuals
get to be experts
about themselves.
I've already talked a lot
about needs and aspirations
and that we listen to the people we serve.
One of the best things
about the organization
skill center that I cut my teeth in
or started out in that
shelter workshop in 1989
was that part of their core values
was simply to listen to folks
and listening is a huge
part of leadership.
And it's served me well in this work
and so at 10:15 I following Michelle,
there's a seminar on when
listening is complicated
so it really relates to that
and I'm sure we'll all learn
from that seminar as well.
Okay now I'm way, way over time
so I'm gonna move through quickly.
I talked about the healthcare stories.
The intersection of
developmental disabilities
and mental health and dual
diagnosis and the services
is way longer than this lecture.
But I think it is really
a core sort of area
that we're gonna have to
improve in the future.
So where are we now
and what are we building
towards in the future?
The scale is just amazing and
you have a chance to look up
We are Here to Speak for Justice,
it is another historical piece.
I swear this is the last
history lesson I'll give
but if you look at that first paragraph
and assume that it was divided equally
between the first two
regional centers in 1966.
Then Golden Gate probably had
275 individuals served or so
and had a budget of about $500,000.00.
Today we serve almost 9000 people
and our budget is $284 million
so as Shelton said that it
has really changed over time.
The world we're in now is a world
without developmental centers.
It really is now because
it's so very difficult
to get anyone in which is great
from a civil rights perspective.
It creates some challenges
for regional centers
to make sure we can serve
everyone in the community.
Sonoma Developmental Center
as some folks in this room
are keenly aware is
closing December 31, 2018
is the deadline set by the state.
And Golden Gate has 67 individuals
that we do the case
management for about 300 now
living in Sonoma.
So we are very focused on
moving them into the community
as soon and as safely as possible.
And there's lots of political
pressure around this
both from the legislature
and the federal government,
the department but that's not
the reason we're doing it.
The reason we're doing it
is we believe it will have
either anything from
incrementally better lives
to stunningly better lives
and mostly on the stunningly
better lives side of it.
And so I think we owe it to the 67 souls
that are in Sonoma that
we have responsibility
for to move swiftly.
I'm not gonna tell the Agnews story again,
that's too long other than
to say I've met recently
with our great Director
of Clinical Services
Dr. Lin with the health of San Mateo
and with with the Puente
Clinic down there.
Those were both partnership.
We partnered with both of those entities.
The Puente clinic was sort of created
during the closure of Agnews.
It's really gratifying to see resources
that came through the only start up money
that was available since 2003 has been
for developmental centers closures,
and these resources really have both grown
and helped our capacity in the community.
We hope to do more with them.
The challenge for us now is
really and Director Bargmann
of the Department of Development Services
is very clear on this.
(Chirping sound)
Oops, I wonder if I say Director Bargmann
it will chirp every time.
(audience laughing)
Nancy is watching me.
She's very great in many,
many ways in terms of
her vision for the future.
But she's focused on
building of a safety net
in the community 'cause
without developmental centers
we need that.
I'm not gonna talk about
the CMS Final Rule,
there's tons to talk about in that.
So I'm gonna skip that
slide and then really wanted
to talk a second about housing
as a component of health.
There's been some studies in Hawaii
and I know our partner,
non profit that develops
housing Brilliant Corners
is doing some other work
with the health plan of San Mateo.
That really talks about
how powerful housing is
in terms of impacting health
and the Hawaii study
actually put dollars to it,
and showed that it was a
cost savings to the state
to house people rather than
to have emergency rooms
be flooded with our individuals.
The Disparity Projects
connected to what Shelton
was talking about with the disparity
of purchase and service dollars
in underserved ethnic
communities is really powerful.
We're starting a couple
projects in Golden Gate.
One with support for
families in San Francisco
and then expanding them
in San Mateo counties.
And they're gonna try to
have cultural brokers go into
underserved communities
hiring from those communities.
Health Promotora is also
to help connect families
to our services and have
them use more of the services
that they authorized to use.
Dr. Rueben has a social
and cultural determinance
of developmental disabilities
that relates that.
A session coming up today at 3:30
and then the self-determination
is gonna be really large
and for this group, folks
are gonna be able to have
a much broader choice,
the intent is of what
services to purchase.
And so for healthcare that
might mean alternative services
acupuncture, chiropractor, herbal medicine
and that will have an interesting impact
I think on your community.
The two of the models that are happening
that are exciting in Golden Gates area.
The Arc of San Francisco has
a healthcare advocacy program
that I became really aware of
when I was working at Pomeroy Center
because we were able to kind of partner
with them on some assessments.
And it really plays a
role to help advocate
and coordinate healthcare for folks living
on their own or in the family home
and we found it really to be powerful.
Okay now I'm speeding along.
I just wanted to end with
talking about Golden Gate.
We're going through a
strategic planning process
and these are all the areas of task force
that my predecessors Jim
Shorter had put together,
that is giving
recommendations to our board
for three year strategic plan.
In terms of how we're
going to make decisions
about investments and
resources in terms of
strengthening the system
here at Golden Gate.
In that Dr. Clarissa Kripke of UCSF
and our Clinical Director Ingrid Lin
were able to put together recommendations
with a taskforce for the regional center.
And those recommendations have
detail to them in the plan
and we can share that
if you're interested.
But really around these four areas
and they're all extremely important areas
to try to strengthen healthcare
for the people we serve.
I did wanna mention, I didn't
talk about The CART model
in the last slide but that is a model now
that Dr. Kripke has been
working on for years.
And is now really launching with a number
of regional centers including Golden Gate
to try to bring consultation to homes
and training to homes around
particular individuals
in nursing, in psychiatry and psychology
and with parent sort of
family support experts.
And we are really
looking forward to having
that help expand our capacity
and make our services of higher quality.
I'll end just by referring back
to Martin Luther King one more time.
He says the arc of the
moral universe is long
but it bends towards justice.
So the fact that we are
a 50 year old system
and we're still dealing with some issues
shouldn't discourage us.
There's plenty of evidence
of that these changes
take decades and sometimes centuries
and we're in it for the long haul
so thank you very much.
(audience applauding)